simplifica 3 a x a la quinta x cuadrada
la propiedad de los exponentes que
podemos usar aquí cuando tenemos una
misma base en este caso a es que si
tenemos ha elevado a la potencia x x ha
elevado a la potencia y esto es igual a
ha elevado a la potencia x más que
siempre deberemos porque esto funciona
así pero por lo pronto vamos a aplicarlo
aquí si tenemos ha elevado a la potencia
5 x ha elevado al cuadrado aplicando la
propiedad esto es igual a ha elevado a
la potencia 5 + 2 eso es a lo que se
reducen estos amigos y por supuesto aún
tenemos aún tenemos 3 a por delante aquí
va a ser un paréntesis y quiero
mostrarte porque esto funciona pensemos
en lo que significa ha elevado a la
quinta por al cuadrado a la quinta a la
quinta literalmente significa a por a
por ahora por a cinco veces mientras que
a cuadrada significa
ahora y estamos multiplicando éstos
entre sí estamos multiplicando estas 5
as por estas dos as entonces que hemos
hecho hemos multiplicado a por sí mismas
cinco veces y posteriormente otras dos
veces primero cinco veces y luego dos
veces pongamos esto claramente aquí está
de aquí es a la quinta mientras está de
aquí es a al cuadrado al multiplicar a
ambas que tenemos que estamos
multiplicando a por sí misma un total de
cinco más dos que es siete veces a a la
séptima potencia a elevada a la potencia
cinco más dos así que esto se simplifica
como 3a por ha elevado a la séptima a la
séptima potencia y ahora te podrías
preguntar cómo aplicamos la propiedad
aquí bueno recordemos que a
simplemente es lo mismo que elevada a la
potencia 1 entonces aquí tenemos que es
3 x elevada a la potencia 1 x a la
séptima y aquí aplicamos la regla
nuevamente tenemos la misma base a a a
la 1 x a la séptima nos da simplemente a
la octava aquí aplicamos la
asociatividad de la multiplicación para
hacer primero el producto de la sas para
posteriormente multiplicar por 3
entonces a la 1 x a la séptima es igual
a a a la octava y esto multiplicado por
33 a la octava
así es que tres por a por a la quinta
por al cuadrado se simplifica como tres
por a elevada a la octava potencia